well that press press conference has
just finished and there's been
a number of new pieces of information
not giving much hope i'm afraid for the
families who've been desperately hoping
that this submarine might be found and
the crew members might be found
alive no confirmation as yet according
to the military chiefs and the naval
chiefs who were speaking
at the press conference but they did say
that parts of debris
had been found they included a torpedo
straightener
a grease bottle that was believed to oil
the periscope and prayer rugs
from the submarine so quite a lot of
detail now about
what has been found they also said that
a scan had
seen the um submarine had managed to
detect the submarine at around 850
meters so bearing in mind that
600 700 meters would be beyond the limit
of where
people might be able to survive that is
not good news
at all and we did hear earlier today
that officials thought that the
submarine would have already run out
of oxygen an australian warship had
joined the search
this morning off the waters of bali it's
a k-r-i
nangala 4-0-2 submarine
that has sunk so rescue operations still
underway no confirmation
as yet for those families as to what has
happened but at the moment it's
not looking that good